so if you live in beijing you complain
about the traffic it's some of the worst
in the world but now because of this
shadow lockdown
there's just really not nearly as many
cars about it there's a lot quieter
slightly eerie and it's bad luck to be
stuck inside but the real bad luck is if
you test positive and you're taken to
one of the quarantine hospitals
the reason for these measures is that
the vaccination rate in china especially
amongst the elderly is very low so we're
seeing more of these mobile buses around
the loudspeakers saying you can get your
booster here you can get it for free so
this is something that's becoming part
of daily life really a trip to get a pcr
test this is the third day of mass
testing for three and a half million
people here but you need a test to get
into a supermarket a negative test
within 48 hours so everyone here just
kind of does this regularly it's pretty
easy
just do your passport anyone ha
schools libraries gyms hairdressers
restaurant bars they're all sharp people
have been told to work from home it
looks a lot like a lockdown even if
authorities are refusing to use that
word there's no end to it in sight